House Majority Whip Steve Scalise is
back at work on Capitol Hill police
received a rousing ovation on the House
floor yesterday on his return to
Congress more than three months after he
was shot at baseball practice we sat
down with Scalise just minutes before in
our cab cameras captured an emotional
reunion that literally brought the
Speaker of the House to his knees a lot
of tears in the hospital in those first
few thanks for helping us kinda I know
you worked with my staff a while make
this day work oh thanks do you remember
the first time you came I do I do I
remember that remembered every knowledge
that one of us remember the people rof
said there weren't many I remembered you
Pam hence came we actually I could pick
you remember we were his hands and then
you actually open your eyes yeah
because Jennifer said James he can hear
you I gave him a hard time because I
said hey I said Steve you didn't even
open your eyes for me no even here I
know it's opening
I've been looking forward to this moment
more than you can imagine
oh you got crutches yeah so what's it
like to having thought you carry on its
yeah I've seen his work I don't I don't
have words for it I can't describe it
yeah I've never felt this kind of animal
is roomy for your president's gonna
bring so much healing to people here
everywhere I go in America first
question how Steve Scalise how is the
Scalise family please tell them we're
praying for them please tell Jennifer
and in medicine Harrison we're praying
for them please
everywhere we all go everyone has been
sending their prayers and it's working
we're just being answered when I feel it
I mean we have felt these prayers
unbelieving all around the country
people that we don't even know and wow
the power prayer is this real power
it really you got your majority went
back yeah you know it was Nam Nora one
of those moments Wow the humanity
involved there and the friendship that
involved there I mean it's it's odd to
see a grown man cry I've never seen the
Speaker of the House you know cry
although John Boehner as he pointed out
used to decry frequently but I like to
see that kind of humanity in that moment
did you all did you know he was coming
or do you were I know you had an
interview scheduled with mr. Scalise
right so we were waiting to go on the
floor they said the speaker the house
was gonna try and stop by and see him
before he went down to open up so we had
an inkling that he might go by he might
come but we were interviewed we also
talked to Scalise after he was on the
House floor again for another interview
and the House Majority Whip said had his
Capitol Police not been there that day
on that baseball field he thinks a dozen
members of Congress could be dead and I
think that's part of the emotion too
because every member of Congress
realized this could have been really bad
and it was an attack on the institution
and I suspect when you know how close he
may have come to death yes and that's
part of our story on 60 minutes on
Sunday this extended for the first time
we've done all the original reporting
about what happened that day on June
14th his recovery and how close he came
to death but that's what made it so
touching to me and everybody who watched
that piece to see the speaker walk in it
was so spontaneous
the way he dropped to his knees
immediately and the way that he grabbed
congressman Scalise I'll never forget
seeing that and the wife's reaction then
he said oh yeah hi Nora
yeah oh yeah you're here yeah that was
when I thought it sort of felt a little
uncomfortable being here beautiful to
see ya thank you guys and just a
reminder you can watch the interview
with House Majority Whip Steve Scalise
that's Sunday night on 60 minutes that's
right here on CBS well they're hoping
well done very well done very well done
indeed